how many relationships have you
developed from being at the sag
foundation it sounds like when you
walked in the door the uncreated you
they had huge smile well thats nice and
it's been a while since I've been back
here because I spent a lot of time on
the east coast but that actually fits in
because um I would say there's a half a
dozen people here at the sag foundation
I'll who work in the officers team at
Tina who you guys met and Simon and
Jesse and I actually just ran into jesse
at a screening recently it was like hey
how are you because it's been a little
while since I've been back here so and
they're all part of the sag foundation
some of them are actors themselves but
it's definitely there's no read as well
so there's definitely been a group of
people who may be other opportunities
come through but so for instance I was
in New York last year I was in
Philadelphia and I saw that New York
also has a sag foundation it was almost
non-existent but what they did was they
sent one of the gals from here out for a
trial and a year later she still there
and she loves it and sag foundation is
now blooming in New York City her name
is Stacy and she had no idea that I was
in town well I saw a really cool event
that she was putting on in New York so I
grabbed some girlfriends in New York we
rsvp'd and we showed up I walk in the
door and she's like ah I saw your name
on the list that I thought yours repeat
for the wrong city like no so you know
what I mean like it's it's not even just
confined to like la like the
relationships I've built here you know
expansive all over the place and I think
that's with any kind of good
relationship it branches on to so much
you have no idea where it's going to
lead you know
you